eb kundgebung hier sehen sie ihn bereits
neben dem rednerpult er wird gerade
vorgestellt in düsseldorf war durchaus
lautstark zu vernehmen
als olaf scholz kam auch von protesten
um diese veranstaltung herum wir sehen
oder auf dem rednerpult er wird gleich
loslegen phoenix vor ort heute am tag
der arbeit mit olaf scholz auf einer
dgb-kundgebung und düsseldorf und zwei
weiteren reden des dgb vorsitzenden
rainer hoffmann in berlin und des metall
vorsitzenden jörg hofmann in aachen
alles weitere dann später hier bei
phoenix von uns aus dem studio noch
diesen die leber hoffen wir auf
informationen aus erster hand
antworten nicht nur zur brisanten
situation in der ukraine und in europa
sondern hoffentlich auch zu den original
gewerkschaftlichen themen wie geht es
weiter mit auskömmlichen renten wie geht
es weiter mit dem bürgergeld wie mit der
kunde grundsicherung herr bundeskanzler
wir sind gespannt auf ihre antworten
herzlich willkommen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen
ich bedanke mich für die einladung
ich bedanke mich für die gelegenheit
hierzu strecken für die möglichkeit das
zu sagen was zu sagen ist an diesem tag
der arbeit ein tag der arbeit und der
solidarität
und solidarität ist seitdem es diesen
tag der arbeit geht seitdem der erste
mal eine zusammenkunft der
gewerkschaften und der arbeiter bewegung
des ist es ein tag auch der
internationalen solidarität
[Applaus]
denn das wissen wir das wissen wir nur
wenn wir in der welt zusammenhalten
würden wir gemeinsam kämpfen für
demokratie und freiheit und den frieden
nur dann werden wir in dieser welt
erfolgreich und gut zusammenleben können
[Applaus]
und darum ist es heute und darum ist es
auch hier ganz klar wir die menschen die
sie für die rechte der arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer und für die demokratie
einsetzen wir sind solidarisch mit den
bürgern und den bürgern der ukraine die
ihr eigenes urteil hirn
[Applaus]
sie sind angegriffen
von einem großen nachbarn ein land das
das andere feld russland hat in der
ukraine nichts zu suchen
ich fordere den russischen präsidenten
auch lassen sie die deutschen steigen
zitiert wird respektieren sie die
souveränität von die unabhängigkeit der
ukraine
[Applaus]
und das wissen ja
das ist in dieser situation immer darauf
ankommt dass wir alles dafür tun dass
die prinzipien des lebens und des rechts
für die wir uns in europa so sehr
eingesetzt haben auch weiter gelten es
kann nicht angehen dass da einige
daherkommen richtige geschichtsbücher
angucken und schon wo früher grenzen
waren und dann mit militärischer gewalt
versuchen grenzen zu verschieben
das ist im wallis muss das wollen wir in
europa nicht haben
[Applaus]
und aus diesem grunde aus diesem grunde
ist es auch ganz klar wir werden die
ukraine weiter unterstützen mit geld mit
humanitärer hilfe aber auch das muss
gesagt werden wir werden sie
unterstützen dort sie sich verteidigen
kann mit waffenlieferung wie viele
andere länder in europa das auch das ist
jetzt notwendig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und auch das würde ich sagen ich
respektiere jeden pazifismus ich
respektiere jede haltung aber es muss
einen bürgerkrieg schönes vorkommt wenn
gesagt wird er solle sich gegen die
position ohne waffen verteidigen das ist
aus der zeit gefallen
[Applaus]
und deshalb werden wir zusammen mit
unseren verbündeten diesen weg auch
weiter geht der ukraine helfen und dafür
zu sorgen dass es wieder so geht wie es
gehen muss dass man miteinander
achtet dass die grenzen nicht verletzt
werden dass jedes land seine eigene
entwicklung bestimmen kann und ich sage
ganz klar wir werden nicht zulassen dass
hier mit gewalt grenzen verschoben und
ein territorium tauber wird
[Applaus]
meine überzeugung ist das ist das aber
auch kein zufall ist dass die
generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen sehr klar gesagt hat was wir
auch sagen und was die meisten diesen
auf diesen platz auch denken fühlen und
fördern das denn nicht der krieg sofort
beendet werden muss die weltgemeinschaft
ist in dieser frage einig
[Applaus]
und weil es um internationale
solidarität geht auch das muss gesagt
werden dieser krieg wird folgen haben
folgen auf der ganzen welt und jetzt
schon müssen wir uns sorgen machen dass
es welche gibt die hungern werden dass
es länder gibt die sich keine getreide
für ihre bevölkerung mehr leisten kann
dass diese ganze kriegssituation auch
noch zu einer weltweiten hungerkrise für
und darum sage ich als gewerkschafter
und als bürger dieses landes und als
kanzler der bundesrepublik deutschland
wir werden diese armen länder nicht
alleine lassen wir werden sie
unterstützen
[Applaus]
das sind unsere aufgaben die jetzt ja
und deshalb bin ich sehr dankbar dass
hier so breite unterstützung für eine
solche heizung da ist in deutschland und
auf diesen platz trotz einiger die
lauter zwischenrufe aber gleichzeitig
will ich sagen gibt es eine sache die
für mich von allergrößter bedeutung ist
wenn wir auch auf diesem krieg schauen
wenn wir zusammenhalten wollen wenn wir
solidarisch sein wollen dann gilt das
nur wenn wir das als gesellschaft auch
insgesamt zustande kriegen und wenn wir
jetzt mehr geld ausgeben für sicherheit
und verteidigung weil sie das müssen
angesichts dieser aggression dann gilt
aber auch der folgende wir werden keines
unser vorhaben beenden das wir für eine
gerechtere und solidarischere
gesellschaft in diesem jahr auf den weg
bringen
[Applaus]
wir sind dieser woche haben wir das
gesetz beraten mit dem eines der
wichtigsten vorhaben für die
zusammenhalt in unserer gesellschaft
voran gebracht wir werden den
mindestlohn den erkämpft haben an leben
auf 12 eur bisher mehrere millionen über
sechs millionen bürgerinnen und bürger
mehr geld verdienen weil die das mit dem
politisch mandat dieser regierung
verbunden haben
und wir das umsetzen und dafür sorgen
dass dieser mindestlohn sich regelmäßig
weiter entwickelt denn er ist die basis
für das was notwendig ist jeder muss von
dem was er verdient mit seiner schweren
arbeit auch leben können
und wenn ich auf drogen und stolz darauf
dass wir diesen mindestlohn so
durchsetzen sage ich auch eigentlich
eigentlich müsstest gute hören in diesem
land geben durch tarifverträge das ist
die leistung der gewerkschaften und
diese bisher notwendig
denn es ist ja nicht gut das ist in
diesem land so weit gekommen ist dass
wir den mindestlohn brauchen das ist die
schlechte entwicklung die wir jetzt
korrigieren aber wir werden weiter den
weg gehen das ist eine gute zukunft geht
mit guten löhnen kunden tarifverträgen
und auch das gehört dazu am ende des
arbeitslebens die klarheit dass es
stabile renten gibt dass wir ein
stabiles rentenniveau in diesem land
haben auch das werden wir machen
denn das ist meine feste überzeugung
eine gesellschaft die vor großen
herausforderungen steht eine solche
gesellschaft kann das nur schaffen wenn
sie zusammenhält und wenn für jeden und
jeder einzelne dieser gesellschaft geld
das sie werten dass sie und ihre arbeit
und ihre leistung anerkannt werden dass
es respekt und denke dass in unserer
gesellschaft und in unserem zusammenlebt
[Applaus]
das geld
für die arbeit
das geld für die zeit nach der arbeit
wenn man seine rente bekommen und wir
wissen manche schaffen es sich dahin
deshalb werden wir jetzt dafür sorgen
dass die erwerbsminderungsrenten
angehoben werden weil viele haben es gar
nicht bis zur rente geschafft braucht
dass es eine der eigenschaften für diese
jetzt kämpfen
und wir werden dafür sorgen dass
familien besser zurechtkommen wenn wenig
geld zu hause mit der
kindergrundsicherung und jetzt hat ihn
sofort zuschlag der dafür sorgt dass
diejenigen die wenig haben besser
zurechtkommen können mit ihren familien
auch das ist notwendig
[Applaus]
und wir werden gegen helfen die wenig
verdienen und sich die teuren wohnung
nicht mehr leisten können indem wir das
wohl des adam und die kosten jetzt mit
dem heizen verbunden sind auch frank
aber wir werden das auch tun indem wir
dafür sorgen dass in diesem land endlich
wieder so viele wohnungen gebaut werden
das ist bezahlbare wohnung für alle
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
geht
alles das wird zu spec und zusammenhalt
dazu und alles das es etwas oft dass
diese gesellschaft aufbauen kann wenn
sie sich an die große große aufgabe
machen wie werden wir es schaffen dass
wir ein gutes land sind mit guten
arbeitsplätzen auch in zehn 20 und 30
jahren aber ohne das klima zu schädigen
wir wollen einen großen kultur und
industrie wandel in deutschland zustande
bringt mit stallmist rietschen ihres mit
maschinenbau mit arbeitsplätzen über all
die guten und trotzdem wollen wir co2
neutral wirtschaften das ist unsere
aufgaben erst die wir uns jetzt
vorbereiten
[Applaus]
und weil wir uns weder zu schreiben
möchten doch vor der größe der aufgabe
ist für uns eines ganz klar wir werden
das so machen dass wir es schaffen für
alle indem wir die in der g erzeugung
ausbauen indem wir dafür sorge tragen
dass dies das land ist das zeigt dass
das geld und gleichzeitig das ist
wichtig in diesen konflikt der gerade
stattfindet in europa mit den krieg
russlands gegen die ukraine machen wir
uns unabhängig von fossilen importen wir
nutzen der hunde habe wir schaffen neue
arbeitsplätze und wir sorgen dafür dass
wir nicht mehr erpressbar sind von
importen aus anderen ländern ein guter
weg das ist meine feste überzeugung
[Applaus]
eins hat sich geändert
wenn ich mitarbeiter denn der staat das
ich spreche mit dem automobilbau mit
denen in der chemie mit denjenigen die
aktiv sind wird es zum häuser bauen und
die zement- und all das geht sie sagen
macht das wir wollen dabei sein wenn die
neue zeit beginnt und wir wollen nur
eine sache klar für uns als die gehen
die gegen dacharbeiten hält das auch gut
auf und genau das ist meine überzeugung
[Applaus]
in dem sinne noch mal schön dank dafür
dass sich sprechen konnte
[Applaus]
schönen dank dafür dass so viele
mitgeholfen haben dass sich gut zu
verstehen
und schon dank dafür dass diejenigen
vieler meinung sind dass der
zusammenhalt in dieser gesellschaft
nicht ihre aufgabe ist eine minderheit
sind wir wollen ein gerechtes und ein
london mit guten arbeitsplätzen und wir
entschieden in europa das ist unsere
aufgabe und dafür können wir gemeinsam
weiter streiten vielen dank
vielen dank
bundeskanzler nach schulz dass sie sich
der herausforderung hier gestellt haben
[Applaus]
alles gute für ihre stimme
jetzt könnten eigentlich alle die nicht
einverstanden sind auch mal lautstark
protestiert
die haben schon ach so ok und will
der eintrag ins goldene buch der stadt
muss und ob muss leider heute ausfallen
weil der hof erkrankt ist
herr bundeskanzler in hamburg sagt man
tschüs da sie jetzt nicht in goldene
buch der stadt müssen sie wieder kommen
deswegen sagt man in düsseldorf auf
wiedersehen alles gute
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja den genesungswünschen für die stimme
des bundeskanzlers den kann man sich
natürlich nur anschließen er musste ja
offensichtlich gegen lautet protestierer
regelrecht anbrüllen das haben wir in
der rede jetzt gerade gesehen wäre das
im einzelner der dieses spektakel
veranstaltet hat auf dieser
dgb-veranstaltung düsseldorf das wird
man noch nachliefern auch bei anderen
veranstaltungen des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbundes in deutschland soll
es hier zu solchen
ausschreitungen gekommen sein ein
bundeskanzler muss ich den diskussionen
in der bevölkerung und auch anfeindungen
stellen das hat olaf scholz jetzt hier
getan heute tag der arbeit olaf scholz
auf einer dgb-kundgebung nicht in berlin
sondern in düsseldorf im übrigen ist die
landtags
jetzt muss ich
hier noch mal unterbrechen denn wir
haben gleich die nächste veranstaltung
geht schneller los als wir dachten
nämlich reiner hoffmann der dgb
bundesvorsitzende in berlin live bei
phoenix
seit zehn wochen
herrscht wieder krieg in europa
deshalb setzen wir heute gemeinsam am
ersten mai dem internationalen tag der
arbeit ein ganz klares zeichen für
frieden freiheit
sicherheit und demokratie
der dgb und seine
mitgliedsgewerkschaften
fordern gemeinsam mit der
internationalen gewerkschaftsbewegung
wladimir putin auf den
menschenverachtenden
krieg sofort zu beenden wir fordern
waffenstillstand jetzt
wir fördern
waffenstillstand
noch mal wir fordern
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen mit jedem
verbrecherischen angriff auf die ukraine
ist krieg als mittel der politik nach
über 20 jahren nach europa zurückgekehrt
dieser krieg ist auch ein angriff auf
die europäische friedensordnung und
auf unsere demokratie
täglich erreichen uns neue nachrichten
über kriegsverbrechen
wir erleben eine humanitäre katastrophe
millionen menschen sind auf der flucht
familien werden auseinandergerissen
[Musik]
infrastrukturen sind zerstört hunger und
elend lassen die menschen leiden
wir stehen solidarisch an die seite der
menschen in der ukraine einer freien
ukraine in der sie in frieden und in
sicherheit leben können
zugleich
zugleich liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
gilt unsere unsere solidarität
den menschen in russland
und in belarus die trotz der
allgegenwärtigen repressionen ihre
stimme gegen den krieg erheben
wir erheben mit den menschen in belarus
und in russland und in der ukraine
die sich gegen diesen krieg erheben
dieser
widerliche krieg muss aufhören
in belarus wurden bereits über 20
gewerkschafterinnen und gewerkschafter
verhaftet
vielleicht könnt ihr mal zur kenntnis
nehmen dass es hier um kolleginnen und
kollegen geht die eine klare position
für frieden und freiheit haben und ihre
mutige haltung
gegen den krieg putins zum ausdruck
bringen dafür sitzen sie im knast
gemeinsam
gemeinsam fordern wir von der
belarussischen regierung die sofortige
freilassung unserer kolleginnen und
kollegen die verhaftung ist auch ein
angriff auf die unabhängige
gewerkschaften liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
[Applaus]
unsere solidarität
brauchen auch die menschen die aus der
ukraine kommen und schutz bei uns suchen
sie brauchen sicherheit und verlässliche
perspektiven
berlin ist ein drehkreuz für diese
geflüchteten am hauptbahnhof nur einige
hundert meter von hier entfernt
kommen sie zu uns und suchen schutz
und die bürgerinnen und bürger
berlinerinnen und berliner haben in den
letzten wochen gezeigt wie solidarisch
und hilfsbereit berlin ist viele von
euch
engagieren sich ehrenamtlich und helfen
unermüdlich hier in berlin und in vielen
anderen städten deutschlands
für dieses engagement
danke ich euch ganz herzlich
das ist gelebte solidarität
aber jetzt kommt es auch darauf an dass
qualifikationen der geflüchteten
unbürokratisch anerkannt werden es ist
gut dass der arbeitsmarkt allen
geflüchtet allen geflüchteten
unabhängig von der nationalität
unabhängig von der hautfarbe offen steht
es ist gut liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
gemeinsam mit dem betriebs- und
personalräten oft auch zusammen mit den
arbeitgebern dass sie dafür sorgen dass
die geflüchteten rasch eine arbeit
finden und zwar zu ordentlichen
bedingungen
und ich und ich warne alle arbeitgeber
die meinen geflüchtete zu miesen löhnen
und grottigen arbeitsbedingungen
beschäftigen zu können
gemeinsam liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
werden wir darauf achten das nachleben
der not und dem elend die der krieg über
die menschen gebracht hat sie nicht auch
noch von skrupellosen kapitalisten
ausgebeutet werden
liebe kolleginnen und kolleginnen in der
kommenden woche
beginnen wir wieder den 8 bei
dieser tag der befreiung steht für uns
als symbol für das ende der
terrorherrschaft der nazis
dieser tag steht für das ende des
zweiten weltkrieges
nie wieder krieg das ist unsere zentrale
lehre aus dieser schrecklichen
vergangenheit nie wieder krieg
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind
überzeugt wenn wir den frieden
dauerhaft sichern wollen gelingt uns das
nur durch völkerverständigung
deshalb haben wir uns immer für die idee
eines solidarischen europas und einer
gemeinsamen sicherheit in europa stark
gemacht
der russische angriff auf die ukraine
führt uns vor augen dass ich sicher
geglaubte gewissheiten ins wanken
geraten sind die militärische
konfrontation putins zwingt uns darüber
zu reden wie eine gemeinsame europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur
in zukunft aussehen soll ich bin davon
überzeugt
dass wir eine engere
friedens sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitische abstimmung in
europa brauchen
dafür liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dafür brauchen wir einen
sicherheitsbegriff der nicht auf
militärische
sicherheit bestimmt ist für uns bedeutet
das auch immer
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
und konfliktprävention und die die jetzt
meinen nichts zu hören kann ich nur
sagen
lasst uns gemeinsam
für frieden in europa und überall auf
der welt kämpfen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zahlen wir haben eine gute kondition
aber trotzdem sage ich euch
wir brauchen eine strategisch souveräne
europäische union die zeigt es zeigt
sich aktuell wie notwendig eine starke
solidarische europäische union ist
beispielsweise am thema der
energieversorgung
ohne frage steht die deutsche
bundesregierung
stehen wir alle stehen wir alle in
verantwortung
gestehen in verantwortung einen
substanziellen beitrag zur
verteidigungsfähigkeit im rahmen der
europäischen union und im rahmen der
nato zu leisten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für uns
ist aber
dies nicht nur eine frage der
verteidigungsausgaben
und hier stimmt mir zu
dass die weltweiten militärausgaben
die im letzten jahr auf über
2,1 billionen dollar gestiegen sind ein
irrsinn sind diese rüstungsspirale
muss beendet werden kolleginnen und
kollegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
deshalb
deshalb sagen wir heute klar und
deutlich nein zu einer massiven
aufrüstung
wir nehmen es nicht
wir nehmen es nicht hin wenn die
bundesregierung ankündigt dass der
rüstungs haushalt dauerhaft auf das zwei
prozent ziel der nato aufgestockt werden
soll
[Musik]
wir nehmen es nicht hin wenn das
rüstungs ziel von zwei prozent der nato
aufgestockt werden soll da sind wir uns
einig
wir sind uns einig dass wir dieses geld
dringend benötigen wenn es um
zukunftsinvestitionen
in eine
sozial-ökologische
gerechte transformation geht und wir
brauchen es für die leistungsfähigkeit
unseres sozialstaates
militärische sicherung darf niemals
auf kosten sozialer unsicherheit
erkauft werden liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dieser
krieg
beeinflusst auch unsere wirtschaft
unsere energieversorgung
und den globalen handel
die energiepreise
klettern
schwindelerregend und sind für viele
menschen aber auch für zahlreiche
unternehmen kaum noch bezahlbar
die inflation ist in die höhe geschossen
das bekommen unsere kolleginnen und
kollegen
direkt zu spüren
hier muss gegengesteuert werden die von
der bundesregierung beschlossenen
energie entlastungspaket gehen
in die richtige richtung
sie reichen sie reichen aber nicht aus
menschen katjas gesagt menschen mit
geringen und mittleren einkommen müssen
stärker entlastet werden
das gilt auch für rentner und
rentnerinnen
aber auch für studierende
für über 10 millionen beschäftigte
werden in diesem jahr tarifverhandlungen
geführt es kann nicht sein
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dass die
arbeitgeber jetzt lautstark nach
lohnzurückhaltung rufen in dieser woche
werden 70 milliarden euro
dividenden an die aktionäre
ausgeschüttet
viele unternehmen sind krisen profiteure
und fahren sagte extra gewinnen
man schaue nur auf die mineralölkonzerne
das liebe kolleginnen und kollegen geht
gar nichts gemeinsam sind wir
solidarisch mit den gewerkschaften die
in den nächsten wochen und monaten in
harten tarifrunden
versuchen die realeinkommen
unserer kolleginnen und kollegen zu
sichern dafür stehen wir gemeinsam wir
sind solidarisch bei den anstehenden
tarifkonflikten maximalen erfolg unseren
gewerkschaften
[Applaus]
richtig ist liebe kolleginnen kollegen
die menschen brauchen
anständige tariflöhne und eine deutlich
höhere tarifbindung
es wird endlich zeit dass wieder mehr
menschen unter den schutz von
tarifverträgen fallen und da liebe
franziska ist es richtig auch das hat
katrin schon gesagt
dass öffentliche aufträge
zukünftig nur noch an solche unternehmen
gehen die ordentliche tarifverträge zu
zahlen das ist unser gemeinsames ziel
dafür kämpfen wir gemeinsam liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
[Applaus]
und wir brauchen
wir brauchen eine lohnuntergrenze
vor armut schützt deshalb ist es gut und
richtig dass der gesetzliche mindestlohn
zum ersten oktober auf 12 euro die
stunde steigt
nicht gut ist kolleginnen und kollegen
nicht gut ist dass
langzeitarbeitslose und jugendliche
weiter vom mindestlohn ausgenommen
bleiben
und schlecht ist auch liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das mini jobs nicht
abgeschafft oder zumindestens
sozialversicherungspflichtige jobs
entstehen das ist nicht okay minijobs
sind gerade eine teilzeit falle für viel
zu viele kolleginnen mit ihnen kämpfen
wir für ordentliche arbeit ordentlich
bezahlung und gleichstellung der
geschlechter in der arbeitswelt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
putins krieg zeigt uns wie wichtig der
rasche sozial ökologische und digitale
umbau unserer wirtschaft und unserer
gesellschaft ist
eine klimaneutrale energieversorgung
ist noch herausfordernder und noch
dringender geworden
gemeinsam
gemeinsam wollen wir die transformation
so gestalten dass sie sozialen
fortschritt und sicherheit für alle mit
sich bringt das gelingt am besten mit
einer starken mitbestimmung
und einer hohen tarifbindung
dazu hat die ampel regierung
einiges in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart gemeinsam werden wir druck
machen dass diese vereinbarungen jetzt
auch rasch umgesetzt werden wir brauchen
zügig eine reform des
betriebsverfassungsgesetzes
wir brauchen zügig die sicherung und den
ausbau der unternehmensmitbestimmung und
wir brauchen zügig die tariftreue bei
der öffentlichen auftragsvergabe
und lasst mich bei dieser gelegenheit
allen kolleginnen kollegen die in den
letzten wochen wieder oder neu gewählt
worden als betriebsräte ein ganz
herzliches dankeschön aussprechen oder
euch ganz herzlich gratulieren
die wahlen sind noch nicht zu ende aber
sie haben gezeigt dass die
dgb-gewerkschaften die kolleginnen und
kollegen die für die dgb-gewerkschaften
für diese
betriebsratswahlen kandidiert habe
wieder große mehrheiten erkämpft haben
das ist gut so weil gemeinsam mit euch
werden wir die transformation gestalten
wir wissen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
eine gesunde umwelt ist die grundlage
für ein gutes leben das ist unser
gemeinsames ziel
die bundesregierung muss die
zukunftsinvestitionen in infrastruktur
in den ausbau erneuerbarer energien in
kitas schulen berufsschulen und
hochschulen
viele dinge mehr rasch auf den weg
bringen und wir bleiben dabei mit einer
politik der schwarzen null und der
schuldenbremse wird unser land nicht
zukunftsfähig
und wir werden es auch nicht schaffen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wenn die klasse und immer weiter
steigende einkommens und
vermögensungleichheit
deutschland nicht endlich überwunden
wird
der dgb und seine gewerkschaften
haben dafür schon seit langem ein
steuerkonzept vorgelegt
ein steuerkonzept mit dem wir zeigen wie
wir
millionäre und milliardäre
stärker an der finanzierung unseres
gemeinwesens und einen handlungsfähigen
staat beteiligen
doch werden eine gerechte
einkommensteuer noch eine
vermögenssteuer
geplant nicht einmal
eine reform der erbschaftssteuer
konnte von der ampel vereinbart werden
liebe kollegin kollegen für uns bleibt
ist dabei ein faires steuersystem
ist überfällig für deutschland und
überall in der europäischen union
in und für europa brauchen wir mut ideen
und investitionen
in die zukunft
egal ob
digitalisierung
ökologischer umbau oder unser kampf für
frieden und für mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit
allein allein liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen werden wir in deutschland diese
mammut aufgaben nicht stimmen können wir
brauchen ein solidarisches ein geeintes
europa ein europa das zum motor für
faire globalisierung und gute
arbeitsbedingungen weltweit eintritt der
klimawandel macht vor ländergrenzen
nicht halt
gemeinsam gemeinsam mit dem europäischen
gewerkschaftsbund
unterstützen wir die ambitionierten
ziele der europäischen union als erster
kontinent der welt
klimaneutral zu werden
als erster kontinent dieser welt
klar für uns ist dabei
das wird nur sozial gerecht gelingen der
europäische green deal gelingt nur mit
einem social deal das schafft akzeptanz
und stärkt die demokratie damit damit
weisen wir die feinde europas die
autokraten und die nicht die rechtsrat
die rechts nationalisten in die
schranken zu
weisen die autokraten und die
rechtsnationalisten in die schranken
der europäische green deal muss zu einem
ambitionierten
forschungsprogramm für alle menschen
werden dazu brauchen wir ein
investitionsprogramm für
klimafreundliche infrastrukturen wir
müssen massiv auf wasserstoff setzen
energie effizienz steigern und
erneuerbare energien zügig ausbauen und
wir müssen in europa auf die schiene
setzen den grenzüberschreitenden
zugverkehr
er muss ausgebaut werden und wir
brauchen neue
klimaschonende
mobilitätskonzepte
die europäische union
hat nachdem sie lange tatenlos zugesehen
hat hat vorschläge für gute arbeit auf
den weg gebracht mit einer europäischen
richtlinie
zu mindestlöhnen
soll löhne endlich
armutsfest gemacht werden
und zugleich und das liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen steht für uns im
mittelpunkt zugleich soll die
tarifbindung überall in europa endlich
erhöht werden die europäische union hat
ein gesetz zur entgelt transparenz der
geschlechter auf den weg gebracht sie
hat ein lieferketten gesetz auf den weg
gebracht dass der deutschen gesetzgebung
das über die deutsche gesetzgebung
hinaus geht und
sie hat ein gesetz auf den weg gebracht
wo wir arbeit auf den plattformen
gestalten wollen gestalten wollen zu
fairen bedingungen in der digitalen
arbeitswelt die digitale arbeit darf
nicht länger in einem rechtsfreien raum
bleiben aber nehmen und arbeitnehmer
müssen in der digitalen wirtschaft
genauso geschützt werden wie in der
analogen wirtschaft liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
all das sind beispiele und maßnahmen die
zeigen dass europa gute arbeit schützt
und wir gute arbeit nicht vor europa
schützen müssen sie müssen jetzt aber
auch vom europäischen rat
verabschiedet werden dafür setzen wir
uns gemeinsam mit dem europäischen
gewerkschaftsbund und mit dem
europäischen parlament ein die uns dabei
unterstützen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
lasst uns europa wieder
gemeinsam gemeinsam zum motor für
wohlstand und
zum garanten für frieden freiheit und
demokratie machen gerade in diesen
schwierigen in diesen herausfordernden
zeiten
brauchen wir ein soziales europa mehr
denn je gemeinsam gestalten wir
zukunft in deutschland und in europa
glück auf
[Applaus]
ja die stimme von rainer hoffmann dgb
vorsitzender ist etwas mehr geschont
worden als die vorhin von olaf scholz
der als kriegstreiber und lügner
beschimpft worden ist auf der
dgb-kundgebung in düsseldorf an hofmann
hat gegenüber olaf scholz einen vorteil
er wird demnächst sein amt abgeben und
hat dann vielleicht auch mehr ruhe die
beiden
veranstaltungen die wir schon live
gezeigt haben in berlin und vorher in
düsseldorf das war etwas wacklig
reingestolpert die gingen auch etwas
unvermittelt los wir machen es jetzt
etwas oder gehen es jetzt etwas ruhiger
an und wir wollen auch ein aspekt
besprechen der bei dgb-kundgebung am
ersten mai eigentlich immer einen großen
raum einnimmt wegen das ukraine konkrete
krieges aber dieses jahr einen eher
kleinen es geht um die frage
tariflöhne wie geht es weiter mit dem
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen hier im
land und dazu begrüße ich hier im studio
hagen lesch sie sind trees experte des
instituts der deutschen wirtschaft eher
arbeitgebernahe muss man vielleicht auch
dazu sagen aber es geht jetzt um die
fragen die natürlich sich am ersten mal
auch auf tun auch als folge des ukraine
krieges wir haben eine gewaltige
inflation im land da spielte corona auch
noch eine rolle das war schon angelegt
unterbrechung der lieferketten die
situation in china aber der ukraine
krieg passiert richtig an den tag
gebracht stichwort immer die importe es
geht um inflation es geht um den
massiven kaufkraft und es geht um eine
drohende in rezession und daraus
folgende auch eine drohende
arbeitslosigkeit das sind jetzt für die
anstehenden tarifverhandlungen die er
mit wirtschafts- und sozialpolitik erst
mal nichts zu tun haben keine guten
voraussetzungen dass das einigermaßen
gut über die bühne geht in einem land
dem sich arbeitgebern arbeitnehmern
zugute halten dass sie eigentlich trotz
allem trotz aller gegensätze immer gut
miteinander auskommen das sind
sicherlich keine guten voraussetzungen
aber die sozialpartnerschaft mal
eigentlich historisch gesehen immer dann
stark wenn sie sich solchen
voraussetzungen stellen musste denken
wir an die bewältigung der wirtschafts
und finanzkrise oder denken wir auch an
das erste jahr der korona krise
2020/2021 auch man hat sich immer
zusammen gerauft das problem bei den
gewerkschaften im moment ist natürlich
die große erwartungshaltung die einfach
bei den beschäftigten da ist und eben
der geringe wirtschaftliche spielraum
weil das problem hoher energiepreise sie
haben sie auch schon angesprochen das
problem unterbrochener lieferketten
natürlich auch unternehmen trifft das
heißt hier müssen im prinzip
wohlstandsverluste die die gesamte
volkswirtschaft treffen
aufgeteilt werden zwischen arbeitnehmern
und unternehmern und das ist natürlich
die aufgabe für männer ist es aber ein
klassischer verteilungskonflikte den man
auch durch auslösen kann jetzt wird ja
immer wieder gefordert von den
gewerkschaften man braucht einen
inflationsausgleich und dann natürlich
auch noch den produktivitätszuwachs nur
was passiert wenn der
produktivitätszuwachs der unternehmen
geringer ist als die
inflationsrate haben den unternehmen
ordnungspolitisch auch eine gewisse
soziale verpflichtung dafür
ein ausreichendes einkommen ihrer
beschäftigten zu sorgen gerade wenn die
preise ja nicht für irgendwelche
luxusgüter sondern für die heizung für
die lebensmittel so enorm steigen na ja
da haben sie jetzt eine ganze reihe von
punkten drin also zunächst mal ist ein
unternehmen oder der unternehmenschef
oder das management dafür verantwortlich
dass das unternehmen lebensfähig ist und
im krisenfall mussten unternehmen
natürlich auch reagieren können und
notfalls auch mal beschäftigung abbauen
ja weil wenn das unternehmen komplett
pleite ist es damit niemandem genutzt
die unternehmen haben wir natürlich ein
interesse daran auch ihre beschäftigten
vernünftig zu beteiligen wir haben ja
eben gehört unternehmen mit steigenden
gewinnen natürlich gibt es auch
profitiere dieser krise aber man muss
doch auf die summe der unternehmen
schauen und hier ist halt
differenzierung angesagt die
gewerkschaften müssen halt genau
hinschauen wo sie tatsächlich stark sind
also beispielsweise ist es ja im moment
so dass die industrie durch die
energiepreise
zunächst mal oder teile der industrie
mehr getroffen wird als manche
dienstleistungssektoren das sehen wir
auch bei den konjunkturerwartungen der
dienstleistungssektor jetzt nach der
pandemie nicht denken sie an die
gastronomie der ist im aufschwung der
hat dann auch andere voraussetzungen für
tarifverhandlungen als es eben der
industriebereich hat und man muss halt
jetzt gerade bei den tarifverhandlungen
schauen wie groß ist das risiko des
arbeitsplatzabbaus und das muss man
abwägen das ist aber etwas was die
gewerkschaften das haben wir lange
vergessen weil wir jetzt fast bis 2020
einen langen aufschwung hatten aber das
rückt halt noch mal zurück wieder auf
die agenda in der tarifpolitik diese
differenzierung oder flexibilisierung
also was rainer hoffmann ja zurecht
angesprochen hat es gibt unternehmen die
und branche die richtig kasse gemacht
haben sowohl in der korona pandemie die
jetzt auch von den folgen des ukraine
betrieb krieges nicht betroffen sind und
es gibt eben unternehmen die wirklich
auf kante genäht sind gibt unser
sozialsystem unser tarifsystem
eigentlich diese flexibilisierung und
diese diese differenzierung heer von
lese gesprochen haben dass man sagt also
die gewerkschaften können einerseits
höhere löhne fordern da wo kasse gemacht
worden ist aber sie müssen sich
zurückhalten dort wo das unternehmen
dann selbst gefährdet ist ja sie haben
ja gerade von unternehmen gesprochen wir
haben ja ein system in deutschland so
genannter flächentarifverträge da wird
branchenweit verhandelt als für eine
ganze branche einer region und diese
regionalen ergebnisse werden teilweise
dann auch bundesweit angewandt das heißt
ein relativ zentrales system und da ist
natürlich nur beschränkt platz für die
ertragslage einzelne unternehmen das
heißt den tarifrunden kommt es deswegen
darauf an ebendiesem
branchentarifverträge auch wenn viele
öffnungen ein einzubauen das nennt man
tarifliche öffnungsklausel damit eben
zwischen der vielfalt von unternehmen
differenziert werden kann das ist ein
langer streitpunkt das hat man schon den
90er jahren immer immer wenn
konjunkturkrisen da waren ging es denn
einen schlechter den anderen besser und
das muss man wieder nutzen und ich
glaube das ist auch ganz zentral in
dieser tarifrunde auch wenn man die
metall tarifverhandlungen
herbst denken dass man solche
differenzierungs elemente hat ja
laufzeiten verschieben nicht laufzeit
also erhöhungsstufen zum beispiel
verschieden wer schlechter dran ist der
erhöhte als später oder dass man auch
durchaus erhöhungen differenziert das
sind alles wichtige dinge und das zeigt
ihnen aber auch gleich schon dass es
instrumente gibt um auch einen
kompromiss zu finden aber das problem
dass vor allem auch die gewerkschaften
untereinander haben da gibt es eine
branche die kann sich hohe löhne leisten
da gibt es dann branchen da sieht es
ganz schlecht aus sie ist auch richtig
existenz gefährdet dann müssten die
gewerkschaften die verschiedenen
gewerkschaften die er und den dgb dach
versammelt sind ihren jeweiligen
mitgliedern klar machen du kriegst
dieses mal mehr und du weniger also das
ist ja auch für die
machtpolitische perspektive der
gewerkschaften durchaus problematisch ja
aber wir haben also eine branche
differenzierung haben wir schon lange
wir haben früher tatsächlich dass die
situation gehabt das meistens eine
branche voran gehen das war meist die
metallindustrie und die anderen brauchen
sozusagen auch so ein zug aufgesprungen
man sprach von einem geleitzug verfallen
das haben wir aber seit mindestens 20 25
jahren nicht mehr wir haben große
branche differenziere übrigens auch mit
der interessanten entwicklung dass wir
lange zeit in den industriellen sektoren
dynamischere lohnentwicklung hatten als
in den dienstleistungssektoren warum
weil die eine höhere
produktivitätswachstum haben als die
dienstleister wir aber in den letzten
jahren den umgekehrten effekt sehen oder
zumindest zwischen dem längeren zeitraum
2010 bis 2020 da haben viele
dienstleistungssektoren aufgeholt
lohnmässig im vergleich zum
industriellen sektor und auch im
industriellen sektor haben sie große
unterschiede die ig metall oder die
chemieindustrie sind immer vorreiter
also da wird sehr viel differenziert und
das müssen halt beschäftigte irgendwo
hinnehmen wenn ich eine
ausbildungsplatzsuche und eine
berufswahl
wofür entscheidet dann muss ich halt
auch wissen dass es unterschiedliche
verdienstmöglichkeiten gibt das ist wird
auch so bleiben und das ist halt auch
bestandteil nur mal einen sozialen
marktwirtschaft wo eben von oben nicht
vorgegeben wird was in den bereichen so
eine der beiden vorreiter diese grad
genannt werden vielleicht gehen zur ig
metall eine frage noch zu der forderung
der gewerkschaften ganz generell dass
bei diesen ganzen lasten die jetzt auf
uns zukommen die kommen auf uns zu und
zwar in sehr gewaltiger form dass das
gerecht verteilt werden muss auf die
starken schultern mehr und auch die
schwachen weniger da kann man das kann
man mit der steuerpolitik marken
erhöhung des spitzensteuersatzes
vermögenssteuer kapitalertragssteuer und
erbschaftssteuer
also betriebliche erbschaftssteuer wurde
da auch genannt ist das eine möglichkeit
tatsächlich da zu einem ausgleich zu
kommen denn in der tat es muss sehr viel
geld
transferiert werden viele menschen
können sich zum beispiel heizung energie
nicht mehr leisten auch pendler kommen
da in schwierigkeiten bei hohen
benzinpreisen wäre das eine mögliche
wahl steuern heißt ja auch steuern von
gesellschaftlicher gerechtigkeit und von
gesellschaftlichem ausgleich ist das
eine möglichkeit da an der
steuerschraube zu ungunsten der
vermögenden und der gut verdienenden zu
drehen dann muss die politik
entscheidend entscheidend ist zunächst
einmal dass vor den tarif roten schon
das problem besteht dass wir ja quasi
die forderung der gewerkschaft nach
einem reale und sicherung haben wir
haben eine inflationsrate von sieben
prozent und das ist als schwierig
tarifpolitisch umzusetzen deswegen ist
es wichtig dass die fiskalpolitik
flankiert dinge wie die entlastung für
hohe energiepreise sind da der richtige
weg ob man darüber hinaus jetzt in der
steuerpolitik noch weitere impulse setzt
das muss die politik entscheiden das
kann man sicherlich machen und wir
werden auch wahrscheinlich nicht umhin
kommen dass wir irgendwann sagen wir
können nicht nur schulden anhäufen
sondern irgendwann müssen wir die
schulden auch bedienen und dazu steuern
erhöhen also diese debatte wird kommen
ganz klar es ist aber auch wichtig dass
andere politikbereiche helfen zum
beispiel die geldpolitik der
europäischen zentralbank
die ist nämlich entscheidend dafür den
tarifvertragsparteien zu sagen wir
lassen die inflation
zu die inflation als die hohe inflation
wir kämpfen gegen die hohe inflation ihr
braucht euch keine sorgen zu machen denn
das schlimmste überhaupt ist wenn sich
inflationserwartungen verfestigen dann
werden die gewerkschaft mehr oder
weniger gezwungen eben diesen
inflationsausgleich durchsetzen zu
müssen